so we've been saving for last the
property that makes expectation
calculating really easy and
short-circuits a lot of the ingenious
methods that we've used up until now
namely expectation is linear so what
that means is that if you have two
random variables R and s and two
constants a and B the expectation
function is linear that is you take a
linear combination of R and s AR plus B
s and that's equal to the corresponding
linear combination of the expectation so
I'll read it again expectation of AR
plus B s is equal to a times the
expectation of R plus B times the
expectation of s expectation is linear
okay that's a absolutely fundamental
formula that you should be comfortable
with and remember it extends actually
not only to any finite number of
variables but with some convergence
conditions it actually extends even to
accountable sum of variables but let's
just settle for the two random variable
case for today now the crucial thing
that makes it so powerful and useful is
that this fact has nothing to do with
independence whether R and s are
independent or equal it doesn't matter
this linearity holds the proof is not
terribly informative it's just
manipulating terms and rearranging terms
in the sum but let's go through the
exercise again something I would never
do in lecture but in a video where you
can skip it or fast-forward or replay it
I'll I think it might be worth doing so
and it is a respect and it is a proof by
the way that I think you should be
responsible for so let's go through it
okay we're interested in the expectation
of the random variable that you get by
multiplying the random variable a by a
little a and there in a variable B by
little B all right by one of the
definitions of expectation is that you
get this expectation at by taking the
sum over all the outcomes of the value
of this linear combination at the
outcome Omega time
the probability of Omega so what's the
value of the linear combination a a plus
B B at Omega it's simply a times a of
Omega plus B times B of Omega okay now I
got a sum over of this of these terms
summing over Omega I can split them into
two groups I can take the sum over the
over the a A's at Omega times
probability of Omega and B B of Omega
times probability of Omega in other
words I'm multiplying through by
probability of Omega here to get a sum
of two terms and then I'm rearranging
all of the capital A terms first
followed by all the capital B terms the
result is that I wind up with the sum
over Omega of the eight terms times the
probability of Omega and I factored out
the little a plus B times the sum over
all Omega of B of Omega times the
probability of Omega
it's just rearranging the terms in this
sum after I've multiplied through by
probability of Omega well of course this
is equal by definition to a time's the
expectation of a notice this is the
expectation of a and that's the
expectation of B times B and the proof
is done not inspiring but routine if you
use the alternative definition of
expectation in terms of summing over the
outcomes it's a Messier proof if you
have to use the definition of the
expectation being the value times the
probability that the variable takes that
value you wind up having to convert that
formula into this formula in order to
carry through the proof nicely and we're
done okay let's make use of it and in
order to do that let's make a really
trivial but a very important remark
about the expectation of an indicator
variable so remember I sub a is the
random variable that's equal to 1 if the
event a occurs and 0 if the event a
doesn't occur so what is the expectation
of the indicator variable well by
definition it's 1 times the probability
that it equals 1 plus 0 times the
probability that it equals 0 those are
the only two
as it can take well we can forget this
tournament zero times something but what
is the probability that a IEA is equal
to one that's exactly the probability of
a and that's the fundamental formula
that we want to notice the expectation
of the indicator variable for the event
a is nothing but the probability that a
occurs file that away we're about to use
it multiple times so let's go back to
the expected number of heads and n flips
which we've now seen at least two ways
to do one by generating function
argument another by a recursive argument
using total expectation now we're gonna
knock it off very elegantly using
linearity because let H I be the
indicator variable for having a head on
the I flip so we look at the I flip H I
is 1 if the I flip comes up head and H I
of 0 if is 0 if the I flip does not come
up head then we can make the following
crucial remark and this is a trick that
we'll use regularly by expressing some
quantity that we're interested in as a
sum of indicator variables the total
number of heads the random variable
equal to the total number of heads in n
flips is equal to the sum of the
indicator variables for whether there's
a head on the first flip plus whether
there's a head on the second flip up
through whether there's a head on the
end flip so suddenly the random variable
that I want to compute is a sum of n
random variables in fact and indicator
variables alright
well that tells me that the expectation
of the number of heads is this is the
expectation of this sum after all it's
equal to the sum but the expectation of
the sum is going to be the sum of the
expectations by limiting linearity so
it's simply the expectation of h1 plus
the expectation of h2 out through the
expectation of H end but what's the
expectation of getting a head on the I
flip all the flips are independent it's
simply the expectation of a head so what
I have is each of these is equal to the
probability of a head and there's n of
them so the total is n times the
probability of head or n pay which is a
formula that we
and derived two other ways previously
and now it really falls out very
elegantly with hardly any ingenuity
other than the wonderful idea of
expressing the number of heads as a sum
of indicators let's look at one or one
related what an example in a very
related example of asking about the
probability of the expected number of
hats that are returned when n men check
their hats in a hatchet with a hat check
and then the Haskett all scrambled up by
incompetent staff and so that when
they're given out again and in such a
way that the probability that the Iceman
gets his own hat back is 1 over N what
you can say is that all possible
permutations of the of the of the N hats
are equally likely and we ask among with
all permutations equally likely how many
of them is it the case that the Iceman
gets his own half hat back and there's a
1 out of n chance that the Iceman is
going to get his own hat back because
this end hats and there and he's equally
likely to get all of them ok
how many men do we expect we'll get
their hat back in this setting well
let's let RI be the indicator variable
for whether or not the Iceman got his
hat returned RI for had returned to the
Iceman now notice that RI and RJ are not
independent in the previous case those
H's were independent because the point
flips were independent but here if I
know for example that r1 got his hat
back the probability that R 2 got his
hat back has changed from 1 over N to 1
over n minus 1 because 1 is out of the
picture and r2 is going to get his hat
back among the remaining hats 2 through
n of 2 through N is n minus 1 of them
he's got a 1 minus 1 over N minus 1
chance of getting his hat his
probability has changed given that r1
got his hat back so they're not
independent all right nevertheless
independence it doesn't matter for
linearity so I can still say that the
expected number of hats returned is
equal to the
expectation of the some of the indicator
variables for each man getting his head
back and of course thus the expectation
of that sum is the sum of the
expectations and the expectation of each
of these we figured out was 1 over N and
there's n of them so it's n times 1 over
N or 1 I expect when OVA hats are
scrambled and all the permutations of
the hats are equally likely that one man
is gonna get his hat back and none of
the others will okay now let's change
this situation a little bit and think
instead of scrambling the hats in a way
that all possible permutations of hats
are equally likely let's think about a
Chinese banquet mr. Chinese banquets are
traditionally done with a table of nine
in a circle and there's a lazy susan
that spins around where there's dishes
of food in front of each person but
let's generalize it to end
suppose that n people are sitting around
a spinning table a lazy susan with n
different dishes one dish in front of
each person and now we spin the lazy
susan randomly and we ask how many
people do we expect will wind up with
the same dish that they started with
after the spin well now we can let our
eye indicate that the Arth the ice
person got the same dish back and now
these are our eyes which are different
from the previous ones about hat returns
these our eyes are totally dependent
much more so than the other ones were
because they're all one other all-zero
if one person gets their hat back it
means that the spin of the spinning
table got back to where it used to be
and everybody has their hat back and if
one person doesn't have their hat back
then the table is shifted off where it
was originally and notice and nobody has
their dish the original dish I said had
something that the dish that they
started with so everybody gets the same
dish back or nobody gets the same dish
back these variables are as dependent as
they possibly could be but it doesn't
matter because linearity still holds
and that means that the previous
argument about the expected number of
people of the expected number of dishes
that get back into the person that they
started with is still one even though
while the our eyes are equal well that's
so much for the lovely rule about
linearity of expectation which holds
regardless of assumptions about
independence or not there is a rule for
products but it requires independence so
the independent product rule says sure
enough that the expectation of a product
of two random variables x and y is the
expectation is the product of their
expectations providing that they are
independent and this extends to many
variables if they're mutually
independent again the proof is by
rearranging terms in the defining sum
for the expectation of XY let's go
through it and again you can fast
forward or skip this part if you don't
want to watch equations being
manipulated so by definition the
expectation of the product XY is the sum
over all the possible values of x and y
of the value of the product XY times the
probability that the first variable x
capital x equals little x and the second
variable y is equal to little Y this is
the by definition the expectation of the
product by the first definition not the
one in terms of outcomes
now using independence this term here
can be splitted to a product of x equals
x and y equals y so let's do that so
this is the sum of XY times the
probability that x equals x times the
probability that y equals y now I'm
gonna do a fairly standard trick which
is I'm going to organize this sum in a
clean way right now it's an unordered
sum over all possible pairs of x and y
in there in the range of of the
variables x and y but I'm gonna do the
sum so I first sum over all the Y's and
then for each Y I'm gonna sum over all
the X's so this is tantum this is an
unordered sum really there there's no
order here but now I'm giving you an
arrangement which says that I'm gonna
love
gather the sums over all the exes and
then for each of those I'm gonna sum up
over the Y's well when I do it this way
what I've got is a interesting thing
here I've got a sum over X and there's
some Y terms here that don't depend on X
I can factor them out because they don't
change with X so if i factor out this Y
and probability of y equals y I wind up
with the sum over Y of this factored out
term Y times probability y equals y
times the sum over X's of x times the
probability that x equals x now this is
the same term that is the coefficient of
every one of these Y terms that depends
on Y and this term does not depend on Y
so I can factor it out and if I do that
I wind up with the sum over X's of x
times the probability that x equals x
times the sum over y of Y times the
probability that y equals y and guess
what this is by definition the
expectation of X and this is by
definition the expectation of Y and by
that chain of equality's I've proved
sure enough that the expectation of XY
is equal to the expectation of x times
the expectation of Y QED so the key step
here was where independence was used at
the very first step when I split up the
probability that x equals x and like Y
into the product of the corresponding
probabilities now let me just end with a
warning about a couple of blunders that
people make all the time so first of all
don't forget independence as a as a
crucial condition on the product rule
for expectations it can hold in some
cases where the variables are dependent
independent is not a necessary condition
it's sufficient but you need some kind
of a condition that in order for the
product rule to hold so if you're not
careful it won't if you forget to check
for Independence or something that is
tantamount to it so let's just take an
easy example to remember what happens if
independent
fail suppose I have a variable X a
random variable X which takes positive
and negative values with equal
probability so it's it's takes 1 and
minus 1 with equal probability it takes
PI and minus PI with equal probability I
don't really care what those values are
as long as it's taking some positive and
negative values and it takes a positive
value with the same probability that it
takes that value negated well that
automatically means that the expectation
of X is 0 because when I add up all
these terms the positive and negative
terms cancel because they have the same
probability so any such X that's a
symmetric about 0 has expectation 0 on
the other hand if I square X then all of
those positive and negative terms values
become positive and so I'm taking the
expectation of a variable that's
strictly positive at least it's with
nonzero probability and a bunch of
outcomes and therefore the expectation
of x squared is positive so the
expectation of X is 0 but the
expectation of x squared is positive of
course if I multiply expectation of x
times expectation of X that's is still 0
so here's a counterexample expectation
of x times expectation of X is equal to
0 which is less than the expectation of
the square of X of course this is about
as dependent as it could possibly be
because it's the same random variable
but it illustrates the failure of the
product rule when if you don't have some
kind of a condition like independence
around there's a second blunder that's
more interesting and and and that people
can fall in because there's a temptation
to assume that if the product rule holds
for independence then so should the
reciprocal rule that is you might think
that the expectation of X over Y is
equal to the expectation of x over the
expectation of y when x and y are
independent but it's not true even and
when they're independent the expectation
of X divided by Y is in general not
equal to the expectation of X divided by
the expectation of Y in fact the counter
example is if X is the constant one the
expectation of 1 over Y
you
Cesc complex instruction set code was
better than risk so I won't mention
names but prominent people have made
this blender you shouldn't